- I think it's the cliche
answer of yes and no, right?
It seems like
yesterday I was filming
my first episode
of Wine Library TV,
but obviously, it's an
absolute lifetime ago, right?
My entire career, my narrative,
my impact on
everything I touch, the world,
it just, it's a
complete lifetime ago.
The day of waking
up and being a merchant
and driving 45
minutes to Wine Library
and spending
11 hours in that office
and in that store
and then going home,
it just, it seems so foreign.
I think I had great ambition,
I didn't understand
how it all manifests,
I maybe wouldn't understand
that there's a man following
me around with a camera
and that I have
millions of people following me
on social networks that
I didn't know existed yet.
I don't think I would
have understood the details
but I'm not
confused by the macro.
(jazzy music)
No, I don't think
anybody should feel lazy
if they're not doing my thing.
I think that
they should feel lazy
if they spend their 12
hours a day complaining
about what should be happening,
or how the system
is unfair to them.
If you're happy, you
should not be feeling anything
other than gratitude
but if you're
sitting with your buddies
at 6:18 P.M. at a bar
complaining about
the man, or the system,
yes, if you're complaining,
you should be auditing
and questioning yourself.
Everything is
being underestimated
about what's going to
happen over the next 100 years,
and everything is overestimated
of what's going to
happen in the next year.
My favorite Australian
wine is Hunter Valley Semillon
as a category.
I'm a big fan, it's
uniquely Australian,
it's a flavor profile
that people don't know
around the world,
it's unbelievably,
incredibly flexible
in pairing with food.
Obviously Barossa Valley Shiraz,
and Margaret River
Chardonnay Cabernet
have far more of a platform
on the global wine stage
but to me, Hunter
Valley Semillon is the real gem
of Australian wine.
If you're working one hour a
day and you're happy as shit,
you shouldn't be
questioning anything
you should be kissing
the world and thanking them
for you finding your zone.
I don't want
people to be like me
when it comes to my work ethic,
I want people to be like me
when they've found their truth.
(man shouting from car)
Thank you, brother!
Thank you, brother.
Thank you brother,
I gotta run but thank you, man!
(laughs)
Stop trying to
produce me, DRock.
What's up, vlog?
It's me, Gary.
My man Justin here.
Justin G from Vayner Sports.
- [Justin] What's up?
Vayner Sports.
- [Gary] Alright dude, I'll...
(laughs)
Anyway, hope
everybody's doing super well
we have a really good meeting
coming up I'm excited about.
Just had a great meeting
with a very intriguing dude.
That's all I can
leave it at right now.
More to come on that front.
Tyler and uh...
Don't worry DRock I
know how to do this...
Nope I don't know how to do it.
Anyway, Tyler and DRock, that's
who those characters were.
Full day of L.A. meetings.
Recording some
really epic podcast stuff.
If you're not
subscribed to the podcast,
make the commitment now.
Leave a comment in
the YouTube section.
Make the commitment.
Are you now finally into
subscribing on the podcast?
Editing team, please
put a little thing here with
garyvaynerchuk.com slash...
I don't know what, is
it podcast? Slash podcast?
I don't know,
nevermind, you'll figure it out.
Anyway vlog peeps, love
you, hope you're doing well.
Headed to SF tonight.
(jazzy music)
74 people on
Instagram bring you way more
than being on a
playlist on Spotify
and it's easier
to accomplish that.
- [Woman] What do you mean?
- DMing over
the course of a year
forty thousand people
that have big audiences
and having 27 of
them use your music,
is equivalent to having Spotify
pick one of your
songs to be on a track.
- [Woman] Yeah.
And then I guess
that will lead to that.
- Correct.
And you're in control of that.
- [Woman] Yeah.
Why does it sound so
simple when you say it?
- Because I'm
suffocating the conversation
in a narrow framework.
If you were hanging
with all your artist friends
you'd veer off
over here and be like,
"This is bullshit! The
industry, they don't understand,
"like, fuck it!"
You'd go all
fuckin' artsy on me.
I'm like, fuckin' stay
right here. This is it.
Doesn't matter what mom
and dad, how they came up.
It doesn't matter
how you want it to be.
the fantasy story.
It doesn't matter, you
and your musician friends
sitting around and fuckin',
complaining about the way it is.
- [Woman] Right.
- This is it.
And so if you just stay
there, it seems super simple.
Because you
haven't allowed yourself.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- That's why.
And that's basically
what I do with my content,
and by the way, they're
uncomfortable with that.
Because it
suffocates your excuses.
- [Woman] It gives
you no room...
- The reason people struggle
with watching
my content at first
is I'm saying the thing
they don't want to hear.
- [Woman] Yeah, exactly!
Exactly.
- I get it.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- But I'm right.
Alright, I have to go.
Such a pleasure, good luck.
Update me in a month.
- [Woman] Yes, I will!
- I'm serious.
(jazzy music)
It's so funny.
I've always been so
obsessed about my legacy.
I always laugh
because I have
this grand ambition
to buy the New York Jets
and I think that
people are so confused.
I am so not driven by money,
it actually makes me fearful.
And when I use the word fearful,
I'm not fearful because
I know how to create enough
and I'm practical,
but the only,
to me legacy is the only
thing I've ever played on.
It's why I feel
like I'm unbeatable.
You know?
- [Man] But it's
why you're acting
on the space
that you're acting on.
- 100%
- [Man] You're giving rather
than trying to take something.
- That's right.
Which is my macro-selfishness
of what I want,
which happens after I'm gone.
It's really cool.
- Yeah, it's all that's left.
- That's right.
So I'm trying to,
Which is why the internet really
allowed me something amazing,
which was I can scale one on one
at a level that has
never been done before.
- [Man 2] What's
like your next movement?
- It's all the same.
I'm only going to do one thing
for the rest of my life.
I'm gonna try to
collect attention
and then deploy
it against things.
(music with heavy beat)
How are you?
How you been?
- I'm great!
I just walked in the door, man.
I had no idea you were--
This is home, man.
I live five blocks
down the street now,
we're a little over a year in.
- Good to see you, man.
(music with a heavy beat)
- How are you?
This shit is proper.
- [Zane] So I go on
the air and I'm talking
and all I hear is
the bass in my voice
which makes me
want to talk mellow.
- Interesting.
- [Zane] Real
interesting, Gary.
Just say this fucking
shit, this is gold dust.
- [Gary] Honestly,
this is like seriously,
the things you
don't think about.
I mean I don't
even know what bass is.
Like in theory I know
it's like that boom boom boom.
I don't really know though.
- [Zane] Yeah you do.
- [Gary] No really
I don't. I really don't.
- Well you don't
have any in your voice,
there you go, that's
what you're looking for.
- Is that true? Dammit.
(group laughter)
- Was that the puberty
thing I decided to jump over?
I was like, this
puberty thing seems like
it's gonna slow me down.
- [Zane] It's part
of your superhero.
- Well great,
let's get right into it.
Obviously I think I
want to keep all the stuff
from the beginning
of the whole thing,
that I skipped
puberty, the whole nine,
so anyway, super
excited, Zane Lowe,
for the Vayner Nation
that's listening right now
on the podcast, on the
GaryVee Audio Experience,
why don't you give context,
before we get into
Planet of the Apps,
before we get
into the experience,
our budding romance,
before we get into all that,
take me all the way back.
Let's spend five
to 10 minutes here on
who you are,
where you came from,
your narrative.
What is your origin story?
(music with heavy beat)
- Of the artists,
you know a lot of my
audience loves hip hop
because of our infusion into it
and just that vibe.
Who's catching your attention?
Who's putting out the
records of the summer?
Who's the artist that
you think is really original?
You have a far more
sophisticated palate on this.
I'm curious, who are
some of the guys or gals
that are capturing your
imagination in the hop hop game
right this second.
- It's tough.
People say, "Oh you know,
what are you listening to"
and your brain just
goes into this mish-mesh
of a thousand things
that you've listened to
over the course of
the last six months.
But, there are
some key artists that
are really standing out.
I mean, it's not
strictly speaking hip hop,
but it has a hip hop
beat, you know, spirit to it.
This guy, Khalid, is
gonna be the breakout man.
- [Gary] Uh huh,
huge. He's gonna be huge.
It's already happened.
- That's what's happening.
You know, superstar, and
you've got all these incredible
artists that are just, Kyle,
who I know you know.
I mean it's
an exciting time for--
If you've seen the cover of XXL,
if you've seen the
freshmen cover this year,
it's like all
those guys put together,
it's like Slip Knot
or something.
Like there's a
rock energy to it.
It's a real tension to the
way they present themselves.
There's a real kind of
like, visceral energy to it,
and I find that
really interesting.
I like seeing
music and every layer
that comes along for that ride.
And it's multi-layered.
Music is only one aspect
of it that opens the door.
- [Gary] Off the sound.
- I like seeing it change.
- [Gary] Off the sound,
people that you've interviewed
or you've seen
interact in a board meeting
or just out in public.
Anybody stand out
that you've interviewed
and you were
like, ooh, as a person.
- I really liked, and
like, this guy called J.I.D,
who's just signed with
J. Cole's label, Dreamville.
- [Gary] What caught
your attention there?
- He has a complete vision
of how he wants it to happen.
He seems to be able
to talk about his dreams
and his vision and
his ambition in a very
methodical, deliberate way.
So it's not just, I'm
scrambling and searching,
I'm gonna achieve
it no matter what.
It's like he's got it.
And when I see
artists like that talk
I realize that
it's not a case of if,
it's a case of when.
- [Gary] When. I like that.
Is it weird for you
two nerds to see that
nerd is now mainstream,
and what you loved as a kid--
Aaron, let's
really focus on you,
because you're a big nerd.
Really, 37, the
ability to be a CTO, exactly
so for you that was
really like a different culture.
Is it crazy for you to see the
thing that you grew up loving
you, the 15-year-old you,
can get the good-looking girl
not the quarterback.
- Like owning an app
now is a status symbol
on Instagram
because the club promoters
have come into this game.
- Totally, totally.
- [Gary] It's just crazy,
isn't it?
- Yeah. I mean it's awesome,
because that's where
the money's being made.
That's where the opportunity is.
Like, Apple and other people--
- [Gary] And the art, right?
It's not just
about money, right?
- Yeah, sure.
- [Gary] Because what I
think is really happened is
app development
and this whole movement
is now culture.
There's a rockstar
status that didn't exist.
And by the way, not
super different than me.
Not that business kids
that were flipping things,
like baseball cards
and stuff like that,
it didn't have the extreme
nerdiness of like,
computer kids--
- Right.
- [Gary] but it wasn't
sports and it wasn't music.
You know, entrepreneur
now is at the height
of its pedestal.
I mean I think it has to
start going the other way
actually pretty soon.
I'm enjoying these
few minutes that I have.
More people actually give a
shit and want to take a selfie.
- You gonna go back
in Building One soon?
- [Gary] Listen,
I'm so pumped when
entrepreneurship
isn't cool again,
because I'm never leaving.
- Right, in college, when I
studied computer science
it was the top of the bubble.
It was 2000.
And there were all these kids
in my computer science classes
that didn't
actually like the work,
they just
thought that it was hot.
- [Gary] Right
and then it collapsed.
- It collapsed
and they all left,
which was kind of
cool because then the
true nerds were
still in the room.
- [Gary] Well that's why
I loved the 2003,
'04, '05, '06, '07 era
because the internet was
getting big enough to be real.
Do you guys get
as excited as I do
that forever, forever,
you will be associated
with producing Apple
Music's first original show.
I mean, you
know, whatever happens,
if there's a season
two, if there's 30 seasons,
it's just always
there and I think it speaks
to knowing your
guys career a little bit,
it's that innovation arm, right?
You know fashions
stars, I mean look.
Until you brought it
up one day in the trailer,
I didn't know that was you guys.
I didn't know the
Hollywood landscape.
To me, that was just very smart.
And for me that's like credit.
I think in a lot of ways,
this new distribution,
obviously Netflix
and other OTTs exist,
but let's call it what it is.
This is the most
powerful company in the world
at this moment.
This is their first
foray into something that
you guys grew up in, right?
To me a lot of this
has happened backwards,
entrepreneurship and
it's backed into culture.
This is what you guys
dreamed and aspired to do
your whole life.
It must be pretty fantastic.
- We're psyched.
- It's amazing and I would
just say that one of the things
that has been really,
one of the things that
has been such a great gift
is that Apple is
really supporting creativity,
from the beginning.
We pitched them the show,
they liked the idea,
and they really
allowed us to make it.
And they really kind of,
it's no surprise that
great things happen here,
in that they've been
responsible for some of the
most innovative--
- [Gary] Things?
- Things, launches, ever.
And they support
creative thinking.
- Design is such a
core element to the--
- [Gary] It in their DNA.
- culture of the company and so
we're all kind
of designers in this
convergent world,
whether we're
tech entrepreneurs,
video makers, platform builders,
there's an element
of design and aesthetic
that permeates
everything we're all doing,
especially as it relates to--
- That's what I, so
what else has been weird?
As an aspiring entrepreneur,
you grew up in a household
that really understood
entertainment at the
highest levels,
what has been the
biggest eye-opener about
entrepreneurship?
- How much work it is.
(Gary laughs)
- It's a lot of work.
- [Gary] Yes, great answer.
- [Man 3] Cooler environment.
- [Gary] I love it.
- [Man 3] Come on it, boom!
- [Gary] Love it.
- [Man 3] So,
first things first.
These are for the
little things that
play between the
songs on the radio,
- Yep, yep, yep.
- [Man 3] All that stuff.
So let's get a couple
of, different Beats 1.
- Beats 1.
- Yep, just Beats 1.
- Back to the mic a little bit.
- Beats 1.
- [Man 3] Let's do
the Beats 1 list.
- The Beats 1 list.
- [Man 3] Awesome. And
give me a Zane Lowe.
- Zane Lowe. Next,
on the Beats 1 list.
- [Man 3] Okay back from the
mic. Next on the Beats 1 list!
- Next, on the Beats 1 list!
- [Man 3] Amazing. Okay now
we're gonna switch--
- If I am not the voice
of an animated character
in a Disney film
in the next six years
I'm gonna get somebody.
- I'll make your demo.
- Haha, done.
Done dude, I want it.
I wanna be a squirrel.
Just an incredible
day right now in the
Beats Studios over
here in Apple in LA.
Got a ton of podcast work done.
So you'll be
hearing a bunch of podcasts,
original podcast stuff.
Did some promos for Beats 1,
so hopefully you're
listening to that on Apple Music
and you'll hear my
voice come through.
Just real good.
Good day, right,
that was really good.
DRock just
missed, did not capture
one of the great
quotes in DailyVee history
but it's actually not
part of DailyVee history
because you missed it, DRock.
- [DRock] Sorry.
- Tyler? He missed it.
But you loved it.
(group laughter)
- But I'll tell you guys this
story 'cause I'm a good dude.
DRock just said, hey
what do you think about
getting a second
camera while we travel
so in case I gotta do
some stuff where I could
put a camera on you and
get the guest, what have you,
and I was like--
(laughing)
- [Tyler] What were you saying?
- [Man 4] I said
I recognize you now.
- The voice?
- And I see I
sent to my son a video.
You talk about your
nature, recreate yourself
to be strong,
to open the internet and
figure out what's going on.
I'm a big fan.
- [Gary] Thank you, my friend.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)
- Hey, man.
- [Phil] Good to see you.
- [Gary] Good to
see you, how are you?
- [Tyler] 'Sup man? Tyler.
- [Phil] You come with a group.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Phil] Good, you?
- Good, man.
- [Phil] It's like a
20 second tour. Guys, hello.
- [Gary] Hello crew,
how are you?
Hello, hello.
- [Phil] These guys
randomly film as well.
- [Man] Yeah, it's good,
that's just
basically how it is now.
- [Man] Oh my God,
it's like the same...
- [Joe] They're the
reason I have a job, you know.
(group laughter)
- [Gary] "You're the
reason I have a job."
- I don't know
how you shoot that low.
- [Gary] You look frangled?
So what happens
when you're just like,
you're just like out
there and you're like,
"What is life?"
- [Brian] Yeah, basically.
- [Gary] This is awesome,
it's a real
pleasure meetin' you guys.
- [Man] You too man.
- Yeah, have a great day,
I'll see ya in a little bit.
- [Phil] My set,
small little thing,
it's literally
2,500 square feet.
- [Gary] Hi!
- [Woman] Hi!
- [Gary] This is
freakin' awesome.
- That was not a choice...
- That's right, I have plenty
of things with my face on it.
Dude, I'm proud of you.
- Thank you.
- Said it a lot.
- That's real work!
- [Phil] It's for
our subscription thing,
our DeFranco Elite thing.
- I'm dying to hear the
update, is the bathroom open?
- Yes.
- Live the luxury of
like, being around this is,
you know, I don't
know when you start, like
you've always had to
know some version of me
from way back when...
- [Phil] Right.
- Just it's the long game.
- [Phil] Well there're not
many people that can say it.
(giggles)
- [Gary] Right.
- Not here.
- [Gary] That's right, it's
the long game and so like,
it's fun for me, like
I'm definitely in
a moment right now,
but it's just another moment,
I've had my moments, right?
Like, were you
around when I got on Conan?
And like, everybody
freaked out about that?
- [Phil] I don't
remember seeing that, no.
- That was what, that was
July, 2007, that was nuts.
- [Phil] Oh wow,
that's really early on for...
- Yeah, I got on Conan
and everybody lost their shit.
Like every blog,
everybody on
early, early Twitter
was like, I just
remember everybody...
I remember being
backstage, and iJustine, Ze,
what's her name,
what's the girl on Revision 3,
Veronica Belmont...
- [Phil] Oh wow, yeah.
- Like all these people
were DMing me, or Tweeting,
like everybody was
basically like, "Do it for us!"
And I was like,
"Fuck, uh, you know,"
it was such a cool moment.
(Phil laughs)
Like Peter Gruber
from Apple Blogs,
like everybody wrote
about it, it was so early
for somebody from the
internet to be on real TV.
- [Phil] What were they
even asking at that point?
It was like, "So
people are looking at you?"
- [Gary] You mean on Conan?
We did a wine
skit, we tasted wine.
- So that worked out for you.
- It worked out.
But it was just, it was such...
Like Kevin and...
- [Phil] Oh yeah wow,
yeah, DiggNation...
- [Gary] DiggNation
was such a big deal.
That was like,
it was DiggNation,
Rocketboom and Ze Frank.
That was like
the Mount Rushmore.
- [Phil] Yeah, I think
the moment I realized
that I had maybe
a long-term business
was when I found out the numbers
that DiggNation was doing.
And I was like, "Oh
okay, I can do this."
Both for sales and views.
- 100%, you were bigger
than DiggNation real fast,
'cause they were insular,
YouTube had so much
more scale behind it.
- [Phil] Right, well what
was good about their show
was their show
served a bigger purpose.
- 100...
- Same as yours...
- That's where I'm
tryna get you right now.
- Yeah.
- Don't think of
it as transactional,
understand how
young and how early...
You know what your
biggest disadvantage is?
You've been in
the game for so long.
- Hmmm.
- In my opinion, right
off the bat I can taste it,
I don't think you've
contextualized how early we are
in this whole game,
because you've got
all the right pieces, man.
Shit doesn't happen by accident.
- Yeah.
- Producin' a show, the
way you do, that's work.
- [Phil] Yeah.
- In a very
different way, just documenting
and letting people...
I'm producing the
show that I would've wanted
to watch as a
business kid when I was 16,
I would've wanted to
watch somebody who's doing
what I wanted to do, to
see if I could've picked up
on her or his cadence,
timing, information,
like just stuff...
- But I think that's
good, you should always
try to create what you consume.
- I think so, scratching
your own itch is the model.
My man, great to see you.
- Yeah!
- [Gary] Guys, we
solved everything!
The blueprint is
set, you guys won!
I'll see you guys later,
good luck with everything,
Goodbye, thanks for having me.
Dude, this is a nerd palace.
- You know, excitin' stuff.
- Good to see you man.
- Yeah man, have a good one.
- [DRock] Goodbye again.
- [Gary] Bye guys.
- [Man] Tyler, Tyler...
- You get a plaque at
a million subscribers?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Alright!
Don't litter!
Don't litter, I hate littering.
(upbeat music)
Oh my God, they're
not joking around here.
Wow, that's what
Apple Music put up right now
when you hit browse?
Airport Gary, comin' up.